Jad. Yeah, let me play you this buddy. Yes ma'am.
You're listening to Mike Nichols. I've been thinking and lane may,
you're getting old and now you're nearly a man and you should start thinking
about your future a little bit.
You know you're listening to rehearsal that happened to get caught on tape.
[inaudible] laughing about God's,
he has a joke in his hand. I know what I'd like to do with my life,
but he just can't get the punchline out without ruining it with all that I have
to train for some years.
What was the journey or even here's a chair or you haven't heard it yet, but
he wants to be when he grows up
a registered nurse. The joke is I want to be a nurse. I wanted to be a nurse,
but he can't say the word without,
without losing, nor can she say the word nurse and get that.
Is there a punchline
and why is that funny?
You will remember it's 1959 and boys don't want to be registered nurses.
Not In 1959 dots from Mike Nichols. The funniest thing he thought of all week.
You and pub. Not Funny, but he up.
But a mother, I want very much to be a registered.
Yes. I love this. We heard so. I don't know why,
but I could listen to this 150 pounds. I haven't listened to it. Not 50 Times.
I want very much to be a registered nurse.
So no, go on that one. Understand this.
Laughter just keeps bubbling up. Mike can't control it.
Ilene can't compel here.
Here's the thing. These are two of the greatest humorist of the,
of the mid 20th century. The United States,
they're professional improvisational comics. They live to laugh.
They control if they try to create laugh, they're all about laughter and yet
left and mix them.
Here we are the species with the capacity for language,
which allows us exquisitely nuanced expressions. This is Tyler Stillman.
He studies laughter at Florida State University and yet we produce these kinds
of bizarre samples.
Okay.
No laughter is this kind of clumsy in articulate way of expressing ourselves,
but it's also kind of awesome.
So looking forward is the question then. Why is laughter so awesome? Oh,
highways, I hate that word. Awesome,
but I will say that it's a good question to ask. Why do we laugh?
What is laughter for and why those sounds, why those sounds. All right.
Well let's go. Our topic today is laughter. I'm Jad Abumrad.
I'm Robert Krulwich. This is radio. Great.
[inaudible]
okay, so to get started, that thing we just talked about,
the weirdness of laughter.
You how it's both like I'm clumsy on one hand,
but also kind of awesome. Yeah, I know you love that word. Awesome.
I'll see why you have to see that word delightful. Delightful is a great,
delightful.
What do I really want to say is that that sort of paradox is something that some
of the greatest minds in history have thought about and written about.
Like Aristotle in a book called [inaudible] Malian.
Aristotle wants to describe what separates human beings out from all the other
creatures. That's historian. Very Sandra's.
He wrote a book about laughter called set and glory and according to him,
after pages and pages of complicated reasoning about what makes us special.
Is it language? Is it reason? Is it this? Is it that?
Aristotle concludes one thing. What?
What makes us absolutely different is our capacity to laugh.
When you laugh [inaudible] go ahead and do it.
That right there. Okay. That is a specifically human endeavor.
No other creatures can do it. Not only that, the first time you do it,
you mean like when your little paper at you just flew in your tiny baby and you
make your first left.
That to Aristotle might be the most important moment of your life because it's
the moment that your life, at least as a human being begins.
When the infant utters its first left emits it's first left.
At that moment,
heated air from lower in the stomach moves through a membrane into the soul in
souls
[inaudible]
and at that point then this is the fine distinction. At that point,
the creature moves from being a human into a human being.
Yes, yes. He's absolutely, I remember it so clearly.
The symbols that clashes, I think, oh, I'm a human being, but, and the but, but,
but do you remember when it happened? No. Yeah.
Well Aristotle was very specific about this.
He thought it always happened or should happen on the 40th day of your
existence.
Oh No,
today is your 40th day.
We wanted to check this proposition.
So we called up radio producer Amanda Aronne Aronchick who just had a brand new
baby girl.
Nina is celebrating her 40th day of existence today.
We're going to get you to laugh now.
Were you able to record with Mina this morning? Oh yeah. Oh yeah. No,
we recorded for 50 minutes. Really? We just like went for it. And did she laugh?
Well I tried pretty rob tried or aunt tried.
Oh laugh. I went almost ugly.
We all tried and tried to kind of harass her and like stick your tongue out
editor and try to tickle her and then at the end she's like, ah,
we have yet to get a giggle out of her.
[inaudible]
made some sounds we've never ever heard before.
It sounds you're making like her level of interaction
in the last two days has been more than anything we've seen really. Like,
if you stick your tongue out at, or she does it back and if you open your mouth,
she kind of tries to do that too. That has been a milestone, you know,
aside from the actual day count, like it really is.
She's becoming a little bien.
It's much more emotional.
It's like you're looking at this thing that you're deeply in love with and it's
finally like looking back at you.
Yeah. Romanda when it happens, will you call us right back? Okay. I will.
Oh,
do you agree with Aristotle that,
that this is the ability to laugh is what literally separates us from the rest
of the animal kingdom? God, how can I disagree with Aristotle? That would be,
you know, blasting has, but none as an academic. I mean, you as a person,
as a person. Um, I, I w I,
I truly believe we're the only creature that laughs.
[inaudible]
what about you? I,
I do think there's something about the way we laugh,
the way we share, uh, the emotional feeling that leads to left.
That is kind of, I don't know of any other creatures that do that.
You can't do that to me. I don't know if we're,
I don't know if it's wrong because in all honesty that this scientific debate is
still a,
the jury is still out on this question whether we are the only ones that laugh,
but it's one of those things that if you poke around a bit and let's poke,
shall we? Okay. We'll be beside you. The question becomes much more complex.
Okay. So, uh, introduce yourself so I don't, I don't mangle your name too badly.
Oh, absolutely. Uh, my name is Jaak Panksepp Jaak Panksepp. Yes. Yup.
Panksepp is a neuroscientist at Washington State University and for the last 30
years he has studied animal emotion particularly, and this is his specialty.
Have Penis in play, play playfulness in rats, for example,
to do acts play. Yeah. Oh yes.
When they're still young and you put them together,
they start tussling immediately.
Well, when they play, they're silent. I mean, no, we got no squeaks or anything.
[inaudible] all the while they're headbutting each other.
They're flipping each other over. They play really hard. No,
sounds [inaudible] that's our starting point. Okay.
So one day Jaak Undergrad students are standing in front of a rat cage washing
two rats wrestle silently. And the Grad students,
guy by the name of Brian [inaudible] says, is it really possible?
They're not making any noises. I mean, look at them.
Maybe they're making sounds, but we
just can't hear them. So he suggested to [inaudible],
why don't we order one of these little black boxes?
They call them back detectors, nature. People used to listen to bets.
What if we put one on the rat cage?
Maybe it will take whatever sounds might or might not be there,
lower them down to arrange that humans can hear. No. I said, okay,
we'll buy the equipment and the equipment arrived and the first day we had a
couple of animals playing and we tuned it through the various frequencies and lo
and behold, it's like our playground f 50 killer.
What did it sound like? It's like,
could you, did you [inaudible]?
Did you take it?
So all of a sudden you just heard this sound erupt from little box? Yeah,
absolutely. Wow.
So now they had the sound that no one had ever heard before.
And there's two things you need to know. First,
the rats would make the sound sporadically.
Each villa rap would make it just like chicken chip, chip, chip, and second,
y'all had no idea what the sound was. What did it mean? What does it mean?
What does it, what are they saying? What are they saying to each other?
They knew had something to do with play, but was it just like a, hi, hi, hi.
Or was it something more aggressive? Like you want a piece of me, let's wrestle.
That's what I think. Or maybe they're excited and they're saying, give me sex.
I want to have sex.
So I think [inaudible] a couple of chirps and maybe it was just a grunt of some
sort. There's a lot of possibilities. 10 years, 10 years.
They studied this sound trying to figure out what it means.
And every theory failed somehow. Well, nothing was conclusive. [inaudible].
Then one morning yuck walks in to the lab,
which she showed us her going to the animal facility on the fifth floor with a
crazy idea. One morning I came in and says, yes, his Grad student at the time,
Jeff, let's go tickle some rats.
What on Earth gave you that idea? I don't know.
This is the mystery of having a new idea. Oh, okay.
So he and his Grad student quickly walk over to the rat cage, pick up a rat,
and we carry it to a box. We put it in the box. Okay.
The animals going in and I began to tickle it. Am I tickle?
It's just like you. You would tickle the baby. Meaning what? Like could you,
could you, could you cool with the fingers,
but you're moving your fingers rapidly all over.
The animal's body or some male ran demonstrated tickle
sound. The chemo is the same as before,
but now it was louder. More continuous. You can see how consistent it is.
Plus it had this very familiar rhythm and familiar dynamic quality.
The way it went in for the first time it occurred to,
Yuck. I'm like, God, if that's last year,
what if that sound is laughter and visually?
I'm going to say it's pretty convincing when you see him do it.
When you put a video on our website, radiolab.org when you see him,
particular rat and the rat kick its little rat legs and Chirp like mad.
It does look at the animals cracking up like a little kid. Yeah.
Oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh,
oh.
To where you're thinking at this moment we were thinking this afloat.
It's a fluke. This afloat. UFC didn't trust what you were hearing.
Oh well we trust what we're hearing, but I said, let me get another animal gay.
Here's another rent ready for a tickle session. Tickle.
Whoa. Syngo exactly the same. [inaudible]. Exactly.
I still kind of said, come on, this is too good to be true.
Let me again another animal. You tickle
exactly the same Jeff. Here's the kicker.
The moment Jaak stops tickling the rats moves his hand away.
The rat starts chasing his hand and moves his hand left. The rat goes, left,
moves in hand, right. The rack goes right. Exactly.
The animal is glued to your hand because it wants to be tickled again at once
more. Exactly. So cool. Whoa, hold on.
I'm just running circles with my hand and the animals running circles right
after my fingers. One, some more. Whoa. Whoa. Okay.
And if you stop tickling and you just leave your hand there in the cage,
like a dead piece of meat,
the animal knows you're alive and gradually it begins to pounce on your head and
it begins to nip at your face. It's like, come on. Come on, dude.
Does that, actually, let me ask you this though.
In terms of calling the squeaking a squeak or a Chirp or a cheat sheet or
whatever you want to call it, that would be one thing,
but to call it laughter is saying something very specific.
Yeah. A lot of people don't like that word. Huh? Oh.
Even my friends have advised me to drop that word because they don't think that
a rat can feel joy or is that, is that,
is that what giving human qualities to animals has been unknown? No.
Since we are closer to the angels than the other creatures in the world.
Uh,
ah. To laugh is to be an angel. He was kidding by the way. Oh really?
Oh. So I kind of believed him. Oh, you think that he was being,
I thought he meant the laughter in the subtle way that he imagined. No, no, no,
no. He thinks human laughter is not special. He thinks the Aristotle's wrong.
Basically. Check it out. Aristotle do an experiment.
Like it goes back a long way back to rats. Back to pigeons knows
and that all these creatures laugh like us and they laugh more or less for the
same reason as us. Hmm. I don't know.
Utila pigeon a good chicken crossing new joke and you're going to get nothing.
Why? Why do you don't think that a pigeon has a rich emotional life? No,
not joy. I have taught with pigeons. Let me tell you. [inaudible] all right.
I'll give it that. We probably laugh for irony. Yeah, we, we'd probably do that.
And like you think of Legend last for delight. I don't know. But sure.
A pigeon experiences delight. What do you know you're not a pigeon?
You forget the pigeon and a k. Oh, take a bird that sings. I bet.
I bet birds sing because they're happy and singing is probably in a way like
laughing. Oh, if you're going to get all general, I'm the, yeah,
it was like the wiggle and wiggling. It's kind of like
why would my day, what's happened to the bay to Baby Amanda? You mean,
did she laugh yet? Yeah. Uh, no, actually not.
Oh see, so Aristotle's really in deep doodoo here. I mean these days,
I don't know about ancient Greece,
but these days people who study this stuff say it's usually around 90 days.
What is, what else? What's the general time at the time?
So I told her to call us back when, when she does laugh.
Message one. Hey there.
Jad It's Amanda Roger Calling and I am calling to say that Nina just laughed.
She just laughed. She actually full on did a life. Ha ha ha.
Like that. Um, it was incredibly exciting. Um,
but it was not day 40. It was day by my calculations. 97. So,
uh, I don't know about Aristotle and those babies,
but I'm this baby here left for real.
Definitely 100% on day 97.
So it's very exciting and we're very excited and now she's crying cause there
was so much effort to laugh. I think I'm okay.
And this message
now for the next question, forgetting for a moment how we laugh.
Let's ask why we laugh.
[inaudible] and I'll tell you why we laugh. Why do we laugh?
We laugh cause something's funny. No,
no, no, no.
The most important thing to remember about laughter is that it's social and it's
not about humor.
That's Robert [inaudible] and euro scientist at the University of Maryland who
got very interested in this question led.
So he went out on the street with some of his Grad students pen in hand and they
listen or what people actually in real life say just before they laugh.
And in 85% of the cases are you editing this down?
85% of the cases. Nothing funny. Proceeded the laugh. Yeah. So, first of all,
if people weren't really telling jokes to other people,
they were saying things like, Hey, what are you being on? I've got to go now.
I have a class, I have a class. Yeah.
This is the kind of things that people, uh, say before their life.
Now don't take my word for this. [inaudible] our cocktail party.
You're going to be a lot of laughter there,
but people are not telling jokes to each other to furious. Right?
So laughter isn't about joking. It's about something else.
It's about social relationships. You gotta have those people there.
When you're alone. Laughter basically disappears
when you're at home alone. Jad do you ever find yourself laughing? No. No.
I sell. Yeah. Do you see sometimes when,
like when I'm watching the TV or something like that,
I can kind of vicarious social stimulus.
I mean like when you are solitary, if you take away media, no radio, no TV,
no nothing in your ears,
no laughter basically disappears. So we have an unconsciously controlled,
neurologically programmed social behavior.
The will only work if there's a sharer, even if the share is just in your head.
Yep. And neurologic neurologically programmed by who? By M evolution.
In this case. At towards the end of the interview,
he walked me over to his a TV VCR thing. He has state of the art stuff.
This is for any fancy,
and you showed me a video of a woman tickling a chimpanzee. What is this?
I have an example here of laughter from our primate ancestors,
baby chimps.
Okay.
We have now a chimpanzee on the screen and you're listening to a chimpanzee
playing with a, a a woman after you get a game going, that's the woman laughing.
She is now puddling and smothering the chimp with the tugs
and he's being tickled.
That's chimpanzee laughter at panning sound. You hear it?
Chimpanzee laughter. A low level of chimpanzee panting, laugh too. I'd be like,
yeah,
okay.
When they really get into it, it becomes more guttural. Like
that sound that sound
bovine things. It has nothing to do with jokes.
This is not a reaction to any other. The tickling is kind of delightful. Yeah.
But what it really is doing,
he says that particular sound is a signal, one chimp to the other,
and those two chimps to any other animals that happened to come by other chimps.
We're just playing Shims have evolved.
It's taken them a long time,
but they figured out a way to signal we're not fighting,
I'm not going to kill you. This is just play. It's the signal of we're just,
I didn't get into it. It becomes more go safe.
According to pro vine, we inherited that signal from our chimp relatives. Yeah.
So basically panting became ha.
Oh, in a human.
We've just added one little wonderful extra the eight.
Sure.
Alright. More than a moment.
Message one.
A video lab is funded in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
the corporation for public broadcasting and the National Science Foundation.
Somebody who has tried to grab my sheet of paper. Okay.
Video lab is produced by W N Y,
Z New York public radio and distributed by NPR national public radio.
You feel good?
This is Radiolab. I'm Jad Ben, Robert Today on our show.
Laughter
and what I want to say one more thing about this.
We talked about how laughter is evolutionarily sort of wired in.
We've talked about that it's a social thing,
a safety all clear kind of situation. Yeah,
but it's another level of safety that's kind of fascinating.
Let me tell you a really classic and not well known story.
It involves the television showed the nanny.
Remember in the nineties Fran Drescher had this very big hit TV comedy series.
Well No, you will probably remember the voice of the dance.
Hello, that's Fran.
Well, what's the emergency mom?
Mike Douglas isn't on Channel Four because they canceled him 22 years ago
and the story,
it actually is not so much about Fran Drescher as it is about the years.
Those people laughing right under the wall constantly. Yes.
Well this is about Franz laughers. It's a story of the nanny.
Last question.
It begins with a woman named Lee set Saint Claire. Just FYI,
my name is pronounced Lizette.
She's a casting director at central casting in Los Angeles.
Central casting is the oldest extras casting company.
It's been friend for years and years and years back in the day where people used
to line up outside the studios and the productions would come out and pick you.
You, you, she actually got her start as an extra. My first Gig,
um, I think it was called the big house and I had to jump out of a coffin,
but I was a hooker. I was a hooker out of a coffin. Anyway,
after years as working as an extra Lizette decided to jump to the other side of
the business and be the person in charge of casting the extras. No,
you're on the phone and production company calls and says, you know,
I need three strippers, two nurses and four doctors. And so that's what we do.
We find them.
Now here's some more background that you will need. In 1985,
which is years before the nanny, Fran Drescher had been raped during a break in,
at her apartment.
And later she wrote about this experience and she spoke about it publicly.
That night was the night that changed everything.
This is Fran reading from her book, Cancer Schmancer.
Two men with guns broke into our home and raped.
Both me and my girlfriend Judy,
who had the misfortune of having joined us for dinner.
We were never the same again.
The people who did this to her were caught and locked up and then things got
worse. As her fame grew,
she started getting stocked and this was right around the time that filming
began on the nanny. And the thing about the filming,
the nanny, when it's filmed live, as they say, you know,
in front of a studio audience,
pretty much anybody can come into the theater.
So Fran worry that someone who might mean harm would come in and sit there
during the shot.
So she and the shows producers decided to do the only thing they could do.
Get rid of the audience, just kick them out. Now,
this was right in the middle of the season.
They had a taping to do the very next day,
no matter how hard things became in our personal life, the show must go on.
So they called up Lizette.
They decided instead of having an audience come in,
just have people from central casting that they know. And she said, all right,
okay, well I'll fill your audience with extras.
I was looking for about 30 or 40 people you had thousands of people to choose
from. And they're all kinds of categories available, right?
You can do a search in the database, you know, height, ethnicity, weight,
dress size, color, you know, hair color.
You can put that all in and it'll bring up what you need.
She needed a safe audience. No, just normal, lively people she could screen.
And while she was at, she thought, well,
why don't I get people who are good laughers? I mean, why not? Yeah.
So with 24 hours to go, she put out a rather strange requests,
put it out on the sequence where it's like a, it's like a work line, um,
hotline that people listen to and if they fit or if they think they fit,
then they'll call in. I said, hi, this is Lizette and I'm looking for a,
some people that have good laughs to work on the nanny tomorrow.
And when they'd call, she'd begin with one question. Hi,
my name is a Donnie Mitchell. Okay, let me hear you laugh. Yeah. Okay.
Hi, my name is Pam. Wes, let me hear you laugh.
Alright.
My name is Kim January. Like you saw the funniest thing. Let me hear you laugh.
My name is Dennis filer,
the laundromat. She ended the phone right away. She goes, let's hear it.
Yeah.
Everybody in the laundromat looked at me and I said, it's an audition.
It's an orientation. I said left right now,
Huh?
Oh. [inaudible]
these were people that were crawling it that were like all ethnicities,
all ages twenty-something to like 70 something. I had married couples and,
and it's, it's not a show like Baywatch where everybody has to look, you know,
Bikini ready and all that, which means like,
they weren't gonna win a beauty contest,
but they could get to the studio and sit down and laugh.
It was certain things that we were laughing at and they would come to us and
say, okay, we don't want you to laugh at that.
We knew when to laugh and when not to laugh.
And then it got to the part where we just knew exactly what to do.
Can you think of anything more wonderful than sitting in a comfortable chair all
day long and being amused? People look pleasant. What do you mean a Laffer?
So how much did you pay them back then it was like 75 bucks and you get paid.
We get paid for laughing. What a thing to do.
Well does that got a bunch of the laughers in a room together just to show us
how it works.
So, uh, this is like a little kind of like a murmur, chuckle. Just,
it's not like a gut wrenching, just a little bit of murmur. Chuckle.
[inaudible]
okay. Something just funny just happen,
but it's not like a whole big long laugh.
It's just something really quick and funny.
[inaudible]
and uh, this one,
something's happening and it's like a little bit of chuckle but then just
something came out of it just making pee in your pants.
[inaudible]
and we all have our great individual laughs, but we were told not to stand out.
So we had to know each other, play off each other.
And if somebody was like paused in their laughter, maybe we'd cover it. I mean,
we were a well-timed, orchestrated.
Yeah.
So well orchestrated that their it services became very desirable.
You know, a chain reaction.
Central casting began getting calls from other sitcoms on drew Carey show from
talk shows sprinkled us in the audience.
And something odd began to happen on the sets. The,
the actors began noticing your life. Thank God,
want to know if we are right. Did we have enough food? Was the food good?
You know?
And for a lot of these people who used to working as extras and being pretty
much ignored all the time, this was wonderful.
They treated us as though we were
principal family.
I mean they recognize us at Christmas parties and as just like we were part of
them. Come and sit with and talk to us. You know, they appreciated us.
So I asked the part I love, cause you know we've got their back. Yeah.
And we did have their bag.
There was a time we stayed after and it was a scene where the nanny was climbing
a telephone pole outside and she wanted us to come out there and do a thing so
that the timing was right and it felt right. And we,
I think we went on 14 hours at night. It was wonderful. You know,
almost want to cry because everybody's so wonderful as a family here.
It's laughters and then reality struck
[inaudible] for a quarter. I bet. I'm feeling it.
Pure disgust with Tricia nominate
George and Erica starting around 2000 reality TV. No,
these shows have made it, no lapse required. They pushed,
it comes aside and professional laughing work slowed down to a trickle and we're
laughing
three times a week on different shows.
There is like this momentum and this adrenaline and suddenly it all comes to an
end and it's like honest to God. It's like going through with it.
I found that when I'm not laughing I'm a lot more depressed and I found that I
found it was great therapy
for me on a weekly basis. I miss it. Oh God.
It's sad. How anybody out there needs any lab labyrinth.
That's a whole room full of us. We look, we could use you,
we could use you look at just the go with me here.
What is Brown and sticky? Uh, what a stick
and Jab. Yes. I had curios for breakfast this morning.
This is Mulligan high grass at Jad. Yes, I am wearing brown shoes.
You're all hired.
This story was produced by Rob Christensen and reported by Mary Beth Christian
here. Support provided by the Dana Alliance for brain
initiatives@dana.org and the extra from Fran Dresser's book cancer Schmancer was
courtesy audio. Our Lefferts interviewed where? Diva Perry,
Bonnie Cheese, Gracie Speranza. Hey, Donnie Mitchell. You Brent Purdue,
Louise Saxton, Gene Vanos does sandy almonds? No Livingston.
Adele Danilo's, Tom Petra, Dennis filer and Kim January.
[inaudible].
Okay, so here's the question, Robert. Yeah.
In that story somewhere there was a guy who had like an amazing laugh. Well,
they all have amazing lasts,
but there was one particular guy who just had like an outrageous laugh.
This one.
Yeah, that guy. What is it about that
kind of laugh that just gets you like, what is it about this sound?
The laugh itself? Yeah. Well,
I took that question to somebody who studies acoustics. Love laughing. Hello.
Hi. Really? There's somebody who does that. Yep. I am Dr Joanne Beck rescue.
I'm an associate professor of psychology at Vanderbilt University.
She's from my hometown of Nashville, Tennessee,
and I study the sounds that we make.
She has collected over 30,000 laughs or so. Yes.
Probably some, probably the biggest collection in the world.
She's analyzed everyone on the computer in
play me a few. Okay. Just a little teeny scraps,
but I'll just go ahead and play this. Yeah, like this one.
Hey, sorry. Sorry to fail on Wednesday.
It sounds hysterical. It like an alien,
but every bit of that laugh she thinks has a secret evolutionary purpose and she
breaks it down from me. Starting with that first part of the laugh,
a little breath you thing, which in her business, she calls a glottal whisky.
She's still got this glottal whistle thing going on here, so I don't whistle.
What's that again? It's the wheeze. Oh yeah.
This is just creating turbulence in her. Gladys.
It's like there's a storm going on down there. No,
a lot of people do the wheeze when they left. I do y.
It always happens at the beginning of a laugh always at the beginning,
which makes her think that subclonal whistle seems really say, Hey,
pay attention to me. And then you get this wonderful sound that follows.
So the way she thinks, it's like a laughers gunshot to get you to listen up.
Now. The sounds that follow, they jump around a lot. Yeah. Pitch,
which again she thinks has a purpose considering when we talk, you know, we,
we keep it right here in the middle. I'm Linda Worth Heimer no, no, no.
When we laugh, we go up to fit it out.
We leave crazy octaves and land on really, really high notes like this.
This sound here and it's like a most squeak.
This note in pitch is actually higher than the highest note in that famously
unsinkable reo queen of the night, right? Yeah. Yeah.
This laugh has got so much going on it acoustically extreme.
That's what she [inaudible] calls it. Mystical, extreme laughter,
which means that it's hard for our, our brains to process,
and she seen this on brain scans.
We get a little jolt a little when we hear a laugh that jumps pitches like that,
25 hertz up to 276 hertz in a heartbeat.
So maybe the pitch jumps, maybe the wheeze, these sounds, they're not random.
She would argue they have specifically evolved to tweak US emotionally.
Humans have the ability to produce a sound that makes other people feel good.
And so if we can do that,
then they're more likely to feel positively towards us and behave positively
towards us because ultimately we want to shape their behavior towards us.
Or what you're saying then is a laugh is a way of the Laffer getting into the
head of or under the skin of the other person. Maybe just maybe studies.
In fact,
we've found that people laugh a little louder and more extremely around their
boss and over and over.
Joanne has found that women tend to exaggerate their laughs when they're around
men, men that they don't know the stranger male she is,
I'm laughing a lot and she is producing acoustically extreme laughter and you
can interpret that in a lot of different ways. She interprets it as,
as a safety thing. The idea being that male's inherently threatening.
So you want to manipulate his emotional state so that he's positively disposed
towards her or there's another way to sort of interpret that,
which is that you're essentially confirming the stereotype of the giggling girl.
Yeah. Um, the giggling girls have power,
don't I know it.
[inaudible]
and on that note, let's end this segment with author Barry Sanders,
who in his book said in glory writes a lot about this relationship between
laughter and power and laughter as a way to stay safe.
Yeah. Were there moments,
early moments that you can remember where you felt that acute?
Oh, absolutely. I can, you know, I can s you, you can't see them with me,
but I can see them in my mind's eye. We'll pay that to fix your for me. Well,
you know, there's a, there's my father absolutely. Um,
utter the drunk and he's turning off the lights and turning on the lights in the
house with such power that he's breaking the switches and sparks are flying in
the house. You know,
sparks are going around in the house and my mother is crying and I said, wait,
it's fantasia. Everything's gonna turn, turn into coloring.
Fantasia. I don't get it though because of the spot.
Don't you remember in the middle of the movie? It just turns into technicolor
[inaudible]
and there's sparks flying and there's magic wand going and Mickey starting to
touch things and they become vibrant and alive.
That's what the house looked like to me. The house looked like magic mountain,
you know, it was the 4th of July.
So I tried to convert it that way with,
with him and did actually worked.
He took a few steps back, looked at the situation,
any cracked up. I mean,
I've always thought that anger and Latins are the root for things like anger and
anxiety and Angina is a word called inks area, which means to be without air.
In order you start your s, you know, you just start to choke up and you,
you tell someone, hey, take a deep breath and laughter is about breath.
After all, this is what Aristotle tells us and so that's what would happen.
He stopped for a second, he shoulders would go down, he would relax,
he would move from out of his throat into his belly and laugh at the situation.
Radio level of return in a moment.
This is Candice currently calling from her bicycle.
Radiolab is supported in part by the National Science Foundation and by Alfred p
Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org thank you.
This is Radiolab. I'm Jan,
I'm Ron and I'm Robert Krulwich and this hour we are looking at
left.
Oh, who is that? Okay. Here we have the laugh box.
That's a strange little device that Robert provide from University of Maryland
Plate member him from the previous sector. Yeah.
Any other notion about this? Yeah, so basically you just need laughter,
you know, cause what happened?
Your notion here is you don't need a joke to start the laugh.
All you need is a laugh. You can throw the joke away. Laughter causes laughter.
No, you can't get a laugh going from nothing. Well actually actually you can.
And he said, I'll prove it to you.
So he showed me a video tape this was at in the mall.
Excuse me. Hi. We're doing a study on the laugh. Laughter. A good thing.
Absolutely. You'll laugh a lot. I laugh every day. Making a white platform.
What do you do that makes him laugh? Trip.
She goes a lot of things. What are the things?
We have a piece of apparatus here. You push the button close.
Why were you, what?
Did anyone tell a joke? Anyone do anything funny?
He's, he was true. Provide is absolutely correct about this.
What we're dealing here is something that's very contagious.
He laughing [inaudible] and I'm
[inaudible].
All right. Well, while we were on the subject of a contagious laughter,
I've got a story to tell you
[inaudible]
going to all right, and now imagine you Whitney.
Imagine 1968 I go, you, I would just sit here. [inaudible] your attention.
I mean, oh yeah.
1962 rural village of Kasha Tanzania girls boarding school girl is sitting in
class. She begins to laugh.
The girl next to her maybe turned left.
Here's her laugh.
And she begins to cross the classroom with their girl joins in and the teacher
gets upset, but it's too soon. Four girls and eight,
the entire class has began to laugh and then cry and then laugh and then crying
and the cow
just cause I don't know [inaudible] anyhow, a girl outside at that moment,
walking down the hall, it's, imagine she hears,
did laughter from the classroom. She starts to laugh and she walks in,
laughs her laughter goes into other classrooms and soon the whole school is
doing this. Laughing, crying, laughing, crying.
Teachers cannot control these girls when they try to, the girls get violent.
They could play one. Yup. And the principal then has no choice.
He's got to close the school.
They opened the school a week later,
it happens again, so they closed the school a second time.
Meanwhile, the girls who started all this, they go back to their villages many,
many miles away and this thing, whatever it is,
spreads up and down the coast of Lake Victoria. You mean?
People in the villages start to play in one village,
217 people start to laugh and cry.
A second boarding school has to shut down and no one knows why.
So a team of doctors, some British doctors in the area,
they hop in a land rover and they rush out to investigate this strange
phenomenon
and this is what they write. The Central African Journal of Medicine,
volume nine number five, May,
1963 the disease commenced on 30th of January,
1962 to mission one girls middle school.
The onset is sudden with a tax of laughing and crying lasting for a few minutes
to a few hours,
a maximum of 16 days,
followed by Russ spite and then a recurrence in the report. There is an account,
a 52 year old
man who saw some people afflicted with a sickness and soon after turning to his
heart he felt something telling him to laugh and cry and shout this he continued
to do for most of the night. No fatal cases have been reported.
This is very, what is this true? Well, okay we wondered.
So we sent our producer Ellen Horne 40 some odd years after the fact to see what
she could find. I'm flying to [inaudible]
to be honest,
I was a little bit worried that I can see the sunset over Lake Victoria that uh,
that the medical journal article just wasn't true. Yes.
With assay that cause that hasn't cause what I expected.
Was this a total hoax or then it was some kind of like stunned getting close.
I just sort of doubted the general credibility of the, of the whole thing.
Okay. We'll be correcting but Koba okay. So I get to the co Baptist,
totally the most beautiful place. The cover is a tiny port town.
It's green and lush and it's very remote part of northern Tanzania.
And my first step was just to spend a couple of days walking around and asking
everybody that I ran into who spoke English,
so I'm asking about this contagious laughter, the demic of laughter,
I guess I imagined, you know,
this happened in the in the sixties so I'm looking for people who are like in
their seventies and eighties it turns out that I didn't need the old people and
young people totally new, but I was talking about, yeah,
I totally know what you mean because it still happens today.
The first time I saw it,
it was in 1991 I went to this tour office and the first person I met there was
this guy named marina.
When he said he thought he could find me, somebody who had had,
and maybe forgive me three hours, I can find out. I'll give you my phone number.
About an hour later I get a text from him that says,
meet me in a half hour hop in his car.
We drive off to how did you find this person? I know everybody in town.
Everybody knows he's not kidding.
Raymond is a former Tanzania national soccer team star.
He's like a local celebrity, like kids follow him down the street,
so Raman drives me up this dirt road about 10 minutes we get to this blue summit
building.
We sit outside on the porch in these white plastic chairs and we just, we wait.
Hello. After about 20 minutes, this woman comes out really beautiful,
has a mole on her nose, long eyelashes,
or she'll introduce herself for me.
She's nervously squeezing this plastic water bottle that's in her hand.
Stanton, Khan. Chester is her name of
[inaudible].
She tells me that in her high school there were three girls who were affected
kinds of [inaudible] for all of them and happen during exams test. Yeah.
What do you remember what the test was about?
It was the morning of the math test. She remembers walking into the exam room.
She sat down,
she looked at her paper and suddenly Gwen and Mocad and insanity and something
came over her. She started laughing and then she took off her clothes.
She started undressing
[inaudible] and then she said she doesn't remember much ups from that.
She's told that she fought. When they tried to restrain her,
she spent three days in the hospital. They would give her Ballium,
make her pass out. Then she'd wake up, feel a little bit better for a while,
and then it would come on again. She'd uncontrollably be laughing.
Then they would give her more Valium. She'd pass out.
Why do you think this happens?
She says it happens for girls are not free.
And so I asked her if she felt free,
like I'm not even sure what they're talking about.
But I asked her if she felt free and she said,
need a quote or I can just tell when you live with your parents,
what kind of your that age, no one's really free.
She said she had a boyfriend and her parents wouldn't let her see him.
But in the hospital when she had the laughing sickness,
he was allowed to come visit and we definitely can beat it.
So this girl has a crazy attack of laughing and then her boyfriend shows up and
she's just fine. Well, we were more like, she's allowed to see her boyfriend.
So it's about the while she's, I mean the real common association with this,
with the sicknesses that it's a teenage girl disease.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. A girl,
16 to 20 d as Old crying and sometimes laughing doctor school nurse,
a psychiatric nurse from the local hospital, a doctor,
and they all said vaguely the same thing.
The reason it happened was that it had something to do with the transitions of
adolescence. And just out of curiosity, you're a girl.
Is there something about this that makes sense to you? There is, yes.
Out of Cura. Yeah, sure. She said, you know,
you're just beginning to kind of negotiate your relationship to sex and boys and
there's these new pressures and these new responsibilities that are really
challenging. It's funny. Um, boys don't, don't have that problem.
We just want to have sex and it's a crisis for girls.
So it does kind of make sense. Okay.
But it doesn't really explain anything about 1962 to me. Why not?
Because in 1962 it wasn't just teenage girls, it was boys, it was men.
It was villages full of people of all ages.
So what explains that
[inaudible]
personally for me, I had found a woman who was there,
hello, that's good.
Through Gertrude is in her fifties she's got short loose curls and big smiles
and in 1962 when the laughter epidemic struck her village,
she got it to six CSO.
Lillian, do you remember? I remember his, yeah. Share.
Ever seen hundreds of people coming down with this strange affliction.
I had took many forms. Some were laughing but lasting laughter.
Then laugh and cry at the same thing at the same time.
What happened to me was I was not able to talk crying only and then my eyes were
closed as if there is a it gum on my eyes.
So my mom, she carried me on her buck and they walked.
I walked over the hills when the mom carrying her on her back for hours and
along the way they ran into other people, boys, girls, men,
even old Dylan's dozens of people all headed the same way of laughing,
crying. I had been yet the skiing where they going to,
the witch doctor did this, which I didn't know what else to do.
When ne hundreds of people, she says converged on this woman's tiny hut,
so do had going inside 10 by 10 in the house. They were fool.
They hit to stay outside.
They are mainly because there were so many people going, too many people.
Those Daddy, what do you think the problem was? Oh,
okay.
I was asking my Erda was what was the [inaudible] they said that it was
something like spiritual,
a spiritual event because one year before this program there were certain
insects.
Yes. She said that about a year before the laughter epidemic,
Caterpillar's had shown up.
They were breeding in the sprayed all over the ground.
There was this huge infestation.
One of the explanations was that the people who got sick had walked across the
Caterpillar [inaudible] these caterpillars and had killed them.
As a result,
the spirit of the caterpillars were possessing these that they do get this
feeling now. She sort of dismissed that as not scientific,
but maybe this caterpillar has hid [inaudible] bacterias which affected the Bri.
Okay.
This explanation that there was some sort of bacteria or virus I had already
checked did out and gone to the government hospital
to talk to the medical officer.
They'd never found any physical costs for this in the medical importance,
which was found,
I'd even talked to a lab technician to the technician who had checked blood
samples in 1962 everything was negative. They've tested the water supply,
the food supply,
you get people negative so that the caterpillar seemed like a dead end.
So I tried a different tack.
I asked Gertrude what was going on then at that time in your village and just
thought about it for awhile and then she said, Dick, you're local. Well,
of course there was independence, independence.
Whoa.
For 40 years, Tanzania had been a British colony,
but the 1961 Tanzania had declared independence and this was right before,
just weeks before that first girl started laughing.
Kartra I don't know much about independence.
What can you tell me about independence?
[inaudible] experienced by then was people going alone,
seeing think drums,
dancing, [inaudible]
but the but from that,
tell me more routine dependence because I was very, very young.
Gertrude said that she knew somebody who would remember more.
Someone I should talk to. [inaudible] 71 year old man.
Mr Sauce was Jesse thing. Dale, which looked at, he was the,
which doctor's assistant may be. This man can help more than May.
Do you want some coffee or something? Breakfast here first,
how my very last day in, but Coba Raymond and I sat down with this man,
which doctor's assistant. We met a restaurant near my hotel.
It's a tiny guy,
gray hair and big oversized suit and he filled in some of the missing pieces.
When we tell him I want to know what he remembers.
I asked him about the independence celebration that Gertrude described the one
stress before the laughter epidemic Jedi Shawn.
He painted a very different picture and I remember
[inaudible], he was 26 at the time.
Kenny Maka his teens and after the parties died down,
he said change [inaudible] swept through his village to do jewel was that we
would assess it. Can you cut out cause it would've sent us was simple.
Immediately following independence,
Tanzania became a socialist state and the new government was out to create a new
world order or land changed hands. They abolished the local clans.
That president president in it.
After the independence and the local religions,
he banned the spinning.
This was the brand new age. This is the new era.
You were supposed to have a modern belief system.
The entire village was being to abandon the way that
they had worshiped for thousands of years.
Thank you. You can tweet about, show me by taking
[inaudible]. Within weeks the church has mapped out. Yeah,
but suddenly they had business.
Catholic church opened up on one side of the street.
Now Lutheran on the other missions [inaudible] people convincing veted us to
join different teens. They even handed out money.
It was kind of a bidding war for souls. All of it was too new.
Too fast.
Does that we would assassin even remembers this one particular night that would
assassin.
Everyone in his village gathered outside Rafa stared at the Sky Kupuna and
whizzy.
They had been told that was the end of life on earth to me the night everybody
was out the whole night waiting to see whether the album today
[inaudible] couple of hours.
He told me we saw the heavens and the moon [inaudible] slamming into each other.
Can you cut out cause I'm going to test this out with sequel
[inaudible] they saw it was a [inaudible].
That's what they say. Looking back on it
and maybe that was the end of the world of that old world. Here's the sky.
The switch doctor's assistant who introduced himself to me actually is an
elected official that's made this jump in his life.
[inaudible] that was a particular period of time when everybody was making this
big jump all of a sudden.
So you think that this laughing epidemic had something to do with it?
Like an avalanche of newness? Yeah, all the explanations I came across.
This is the one that makes the most sense to me. It's plausible to me too,
because you got a loss of religion and arrival of a new religion,
a loss of a political culture, a new leader,
and that's a very large pile up of change all of a sudden. Yeah,
and of course everyone's a little bit scared,
so there's quiet and then someone starts to laugh. You know,
who knows why that first girl went crazy and why she started making crazy
laughing noises, but it was like people saw that and they were like, oh God.
I feel like that too. It sounds like laughter,
but you could think of it as like a collective scream or something. Yeah,
like the entire society. It was a 16 year old girl
[inaudible]
in 1962 Radiolab, producer Ellen and Warren.
Well that's it for us, at least for now.
For more information on the Tanzania left epidemic or anything else you heard in
this hour, visit
radiolab.org I'm Javonne Ron and I remember killer. We'll see later.
Radio lab is produced by Jad Abumrad, Lulu Miller, Bob Christiansen, Ellen Horn,
Elizabeth Giddens, production support production, the
production support by Sally hardships. Sarah Pellegrini area, Alaska,
Heather Radke, Michael, Orion, McManus, and Soren Wheeler.
[inaudible] thanks to Gail cleaver, Beth Barack, Bingo nightly, Emily Webber,
and Sharon Hill. And finally special thanks to Casey Crawford.
Radiolab is produced by W NYC,
New York public radio and distributed by NPR national public radio.